good morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome you to this meeting of the
community and resources committee I was
starting to YouTube yet
proper job
first of all I tried to tell you there's
no fire alarms or anything scheduled
this morning so if it goes off get out
second brain is for all members
they
checked the recording of our last
meeting in this room
and
unfortunately you were all very faint
[Music]
and therefore I would ask you today to
do like I have when the microphone in
much closer to your mouth
so that Joe public can actually hear
what he's saying
okay
so remove one item one apologies for
absence
that's it I think thank you chair item
two public contributions I have one
person wishing to speak
which is true with Jones of the plow
it may be sensible if you come down and
take that chair madam and the microphone
on for you
and move it closer to you
proper job thank you
thank you very much my name is Trina yes
I'm the general manager at the park
intern
um
in 2025 the player will be 50 years old
and with that in mind
um we set ourselves a target of building
a career business plan which I think has
been shared with some officers of this
Council
um our history is I'm sure as most of
you know providing a broad range of
cultural activities to the people of
torridge and the broader areas of Devon
and you know we're looking forward to
celebrating 50 years of that cultural
provision
currently we employ up to 19 people and
yes I'm dropping out
is that okay
thank you we have a payload of staff and
Freelancers approaching a quarter of a
million pounds that money of course is
spent and invested in in this fine area
we buy from local suppliers in the
region of 50 000 pounds are spent on
local produce beers Insiders for our
caffeine or other parts of our operation
before covid our um ticket sales were in
the region of 650 000 pounds a year now
obviously since the pandemic not only
have we
um has our business changed our customer
Behavior has changed so much as well so
these are hard times and we are trying
to focus on attracting great funding
from other sources in order to balance
our books
part of our business planning was to
approach the Arts Council of England for
National portfolio organization funding
which we did last year and happily we
were awarded
um
applied for which is 120 000 pounds a
year for three years
so that's 360
000 pounds worth of new money coming
into this this region that's application
was predicated on some local Authority
support
clearly the Arts Council of 18 that's
where they put their money others will
follow and and value the import of
cultural provision in the region
so in order to absolutely finesse our
three-year plan and indeed possibly a
five-year plan we need to be confident
that we can attract support from torrage
and other local authorities part of our
business plan was to increase provision
in this region we have had success in
North 7 by working with Saint Ann's in
Barnstaple and Barnstable town Council
actually found 60 of that operation so
it's
self-sustaining Hub providing cultural
activity in Barnstable so it's a very
good example of how our Outreach if you
like has been successful
and it's not unusual for local
authorities to as I'm sure you know to
find up to a quarter of uh cultural
provision in their region
we are very embedded in the cultural
strategy of Northern Devon we've been
very heavily involved in the process of
developing that obviously we feel very
strongly about anxious and wish that
strategy to succeed and grow and prosper
clearly that is part of this council's
responsibility to ensure the success of
as well
[Music]
area now in terms of making sure um we
deliver on that
so we would ask that you as counselors
would encourage your senior
representatives to engage with us at the
plow to look at the future and to help
support our business planning and
increase the provision of cultural
activity in
intelligence Devon Northern Devon should
I say
we all know that culture is vital for
the health and well-being of individuals
it's
Central to economic Redevelopment and we
would urge that you engage with us and
discuss how we make it to our golden
anniversary in 2025
thank you very much
thank you
we won't debate it at this stage will
move on later to the debate on the
player and many other things
items through Declarations of Interest I
think the one oh yes um
in relation to the 106.
uh item for agreement with the agenda
between Parts one and two
as far as we are concerned at the moment
we don't believe that there is any part
two
if we get things which are commercially
sensitive
that sort of thing that is when we move
into part two we don't anticipate that
we shall do so today
item five
urgent matters of information built
forward by now itself I have nothing to
exactly
so we can move on to item six the
section 106 monitoring fees
so
Helen is going to deal with that the
planning manager of Tides Council
good morning members and officers and
the purpose of this report is to
consider a proposal for the introduction
of section 106 monitoring fees and I'm
sure you're going to wear section 106
um Agreements are formal Deeds made
pursuant to the Town Country planning
act in 1990 and specifically section
106. and the role of section 106
agreements is to secure planning
obligations and to mitigate the impact
of development section 106's can
restrict the use of land or require
specific uses of land but mostly they're
utilized to secure Financial
contributions or direct on-site
provision to mitigate the impact of
development so this can range from
contributions towards public open space
or on-site provision of public open
space and affordable housing that can be
a commuted off-site some or usually
on-site provision
etc etc and members will be aware
through sort of direct consultation with
officers the important role that section
106 has played
um any section 106 obligation has to
meet the test set out and the community
infrastructure level regulations of 2010
so known as the Civil Rights and there
was a 2019 Amendment to the Civil Rights
and this included a new provision
entitled local planning authorities to
charge a monitoring fee for the
oversight of
um compliance section 106 obligations
but it's important to note the rugs are
very clear in met any such fee has to be
fair and reasonable and based on the
actual costs of monitoring it can't be
to generate additional profit beyond
that
um no formal section 106 monitoring fee
has ever been charged by tourist Council
um given the permissive framework
legislative framework before us and the
importance of effective monitoring of
section 106 obligations it is considered
appropriate to introduce such a
monitoring fee and within your agenda
report at table one there is
um the little outcome of a benchmarking
marking exercise and it sets out over
Devon councils and their approach to
section 106 monitoring you'll see that
there isn't be aware of examples from
other authorities but it's quite limited
and haven't looked at the sort of
approach around the county I think the
Devon council's approach seems the most
robust in complying with the tests of
being fair and reasonable and any cost
or charge being directly related to the
cost of monitoring
so the the proposed fee schedule has
been developed on that basis and
appendix one sets out and the proposed
charges across five bands and these have
been established with regard to officer
time involved in recording and
monitoring and Reporting and planning
obligations and there's a list of tasks
both at appendix 2 and within your
report and that those tasks take place
over a period of time over the life of
the section 106 agreement and are
carried out by a range of officers
section 106 monitoring doesn't tend to
fall to just one officer there is a
names of section 106 monitoring role but
also are planning policy team play a
role as well and
and and are um Community Leisure officer
so it is quite a team effort and the
fees have been established by breaking
down the the sort of average time that's
spent on each of those tasks by each of
the respective officers and then simply
multiplying the time by the cost of the
on an hourly rate of the officers
the five bans have been developed based
on scale of developments a number of
dwellings
um this seems a reasonable approach and
removes any requirements for officers on
an application by application basis to
have to calculate a fee and monitoring
fees would be secured via a contractual
government government in section 106
agreement and this is on top of any
charge that we recoup for the the actual
legal costs of preparing a section 106
and the monitoring fee is payable at the
time of execution of the section 106.
um
importantly remembered information
in the planning team we use the uniform
is our main I.T system and there's a
specific module within the uniform
package that deals with section 106
monitoring and we have
um
with their support of iot ensured that
that has been upgraded and tested so the
system is ready to go and basically
involves at the time of a section 106
being completed all of the different
obligations being uploaded onto that
system with
um clear triggers for monitoring so it
just makes it much more effective
arrangement for monitoring and I have
included in the report just
um an estimate based on the section
106's that have been signed over the
last two years and had we already
introduced such a free provision we
could have recouped cost in the region
of a hundred thousand pounds so it is
um
worthwhile doing to ensure that we have
that that resource in place and the
implications of this introduced in this
provision are all set out in your report
and I have consulted with councilor P
Watson lead member for planning and his
his views are set out in the report and
so just to finish the recommendation
before you is that the committee
approves the introduction of a new
charging mechanism for section 106
monitoring as proposed and set out in
appendix one to take effect from the 1st
of April this year thank you
thank you chair and thank you Helen for
the report this came out from the budget
working group originally
and also when we look at what's
happening is our officers are either
chasing developers to keep up to date
with 106's which is costing us money or
some of the 106s are not being
implemented when they should do so this
encapsulates all of that as a way
forward we our officers can keep an eye
on the 106 and we know that the it will
encourage the developers not to do what
they have been doing which is just to
skirt around some of the conditions
so I fully support it and recommend it
to the committee thank you chair
thank you
um yeah I sit on the budget working
group and I think it's great ideas but
to strike me it's a bit too late really
because
um Helen mentioned the 2122 we would
have earned a hundred thousand but
that's probably the period when we've
seen all the developers piling with
their planning applications because of
the five-year land supply problem
um what I want to know is
how many of those large developments the
ones over 50 houses how many of them
have yet to sign the section 106 because
clearly we can't make it retrospective
but it would be good to know how much we
might get
do you know
um so there are a few large developments
that are very close to having the sexual
monotics sign so developments are
actually our plans committee considered
back in the Autumn so winxford for
example however that that will be signed
within the next sort of couple weeks we
can't delay signing of it until the 1st
of April
um so that's one that would be missed
unfortunately there are still some of
our allocations to come forward but
you're absolutely right councilor
Christie that's a real opportune time
the busy period with lots of large
developments has has passed
um but yeah what I would say is even the
smallest there of development we do get
lots of developments that are say one to
five or one to ten dwellings and whilst
that is the lowest monitoring fee that
would that would um you know add up
quite quickly in terms of them
supporting the resource that goes into
monitoring both the large and small
applications but I'm afraid I don't have
an exact figure to suggest but we could
recoup from the first of April it will
more likely be applications that we
haven't received yet
what I'm concern is is there any
evidence to show that if developers know
about this additional fee to pay that
they would reduce their section 106
contributions
um so as certainly members of the plans
committee will be aware there is a
provision within our local plan for
viability to be tested
um which we are seeing on a number of
sites and that's a viability process
um that very much looks at costs versus
developer profit and introduce them a
section 106 monitoring fee that cost
would be factored in to that
um but what I would say certainly the
larger scale fees if you're looking at
200 plus dwellings the level of
contribution coming forward in section
106 for a development of that scale
you're talking sort of usually in the
millions so you would expect that a
Fourier Circa 9 000 pounds isn't going
to have a significant impact but it
would be factored in
um it is probably the smaller scale of
development where there could
potentially be that that bigger impact
but certainly in discussions with mid
Devon Council officers though introduced
the fees last year and they've had no no
challenge to the feeding Incorporated
and there is a legislative provision for
it
thank you chair um
the road developer has been used a
couple of times already this morning and
I don't have a problem with what the
proposed here but a question that I've
got is the alternate page nine the one
to five dwellings from one to ten so
does that mean that a private individual
that wants to build a house one house in
a garden the rules apply to them as well
the one of the one house yeah so that's
um
that's where purely I guess the scale
but it's it's unlikely that any
development of two one to two dwellings
would have a section 106 agreement
um in terms of when we secure monies
three dwellings and above we Secure
Public open space off-site contributions
so it would only be from that scale of
development up and that would certainly
be at that lower monitoring fee it would
you would only secure on a single
dwelling if there was for example
um a local needs element to it that
needed to be monitored but the vast
majority of one and two dwelling
developments would not would not be
subject to this because they wouldn't
have a section 106.
as far as developers are concerned
they're both too concerned about the
figures here as Helen's pointed out and
the vast summons they talk about anyway
I seem to be quite happy they haven't
paid anything for so long
um and I I fully support this thank you
yes I support it it's all very common
sense
now you're just about to have a new
Council and I urge the officers to be
open up front get the training early
it's very important for World members to
understand
how they can benefit
Etc and the disease important that when
an outline application comes in that is
when the ward members are consulted
I just feel it's very very important
thank you
thank you chair uh section 106 has been
an issue that this Council have talked
about frequently I think and fully
support this report
my only comment is about one of the
issues that we've debated quite often in
this chamber is the lack of knowledge of
local councilors where their section
106's stand
now I know what you've got quarterly
website updates and risk reports to
management I'd like that to include risk
reports to members as well
and that way we will actually stay in
touch with the position and be able to
see how effective it is and whether
especially when members are representing
interests in their community that
they're fully in touch with the progress
that's being made
it will cut down on the calls to
planning to find out what's happening
and I think it would be really effective
so I am fully supportive of the
recommendation we've been inclusion in
the appendix and the process that
members are included with update
thank you
no one else wishing to speak on the
matter from the chair I'm going to
propose that we accept the
recommendation with the variation that
members be included on the risk
assessment is there a secondary oh
apology I had a proposal from councilor
James yes but I've made a moment if you
like
members into it
thank you
councilor James got a secondary can we
go straight to my proposal
your withdrawal worse so I put my
proposal to the vote those in favor
please show
that is unanimous no one abstention
thank you
all right
to
[Applause]
ultimate seven things and charges Pages
11 to 32.
today
[Music]
thank you
um so the council charges for a range of
services and activities receiving around
7.2 million per annum
some fees are not subject to approval as
they're prescribed by statutes but
others can be set at the discretion of
the council
each year around September service
managers are required to review the
discretionary fees in their areas and
set them or propose them for the
upcoming year
similar fees and charges for next year
such as the main car parking and the
borrows fees have already been agreed by
full Council
so the fees for consideration today are
not an exhaustive list of everything the
council charges for
test the discretionary fees which are
not subject to statute or separate
approval process
one setting the fees I do ask each
manager to provide a brief note
explaining the main drivers behind it
I've tried to summarize this on each
page for your information and
unsurprisingly if inflationary pressures
were the main overall Factor
the recommendation for members today is
to approve the fees and charges are set
out in the appendix
foreign
I propose we accept it as printed
retreat
anyone else
all those in favor please show
that is
thank you very much
foreign
-off Financial contribution of 25 000
pounds being agreed but also a
commitment to bring a further report
back to consider the need and
availability from the Council of future
help so this is what this report's about
um in preparing the report there are
three documents three key documents have
been considered those are listed there
and the business plan is appended and
the most notable
um points that we've extracted in terms
of the finances from the 23 24
monitoring position are that the place
for forecasting a break even position
for the financial year 23 and that's
largely due to receiving 120 000 pounds
worth of NPO status funding as Trina
mentioned earlier on in her statement uh
there isn't a breakdown within that
document of the anticipated local
Authority contribution says 50 000
pounds but doesn't necessarily say which
organization would pay what to make up
that fifty thousand pounds and as at the
close of March 24 the players projecting
to have cash balances of Circa 159
000 pounds assuming they receive 50 000
pounds of local Authority contributions
and the business plan refers to uh
substantial designated reserves uh it
doesn't provide breakdown of those but
they're in a total of 283 000 pounds
document uh which I assume was uh
presented as part of the mpo application
sets out of strategies for increasing
income and also developing audiences and
that's much of what Trina was talking
about earlier on and obviously the
achievement of that status is fantastic
for the area and for the organization
financially
uh the report uh also considers the
council's financial position
and it's in to summarize that we haven't
budgeted for any Financial ongoing
financial support for the plan and if
members were to resolve to do that you
would be adding to your budget deficit
position which we'll obviously consider
later
there's a contribution from the lead
member councilor cotton in support of
helping the player
and and I think you know there are a
number of conclusions that are set out
in the report but to to bring them uh
together in a nutshell it is that the
the player is a a fantastic resource for
the area it's a it's a partner
organization in delivering the cultural
strategy uh it does much work for the
center of Torrington and the community
beyond that and there's a driver of both
culture and economic activity but that
the council is in a very difficult
financial position and we don't have the
resources at the moment to recommend the
contribution towards the operations of
the play
so that brings us finally choose the
recommendation that in the knowledge of
the council's medium-term financial
strategy report and it shows a
cumulative deficit of 1.2 million pounds
membership result whether or not to
provide a contribution towards the core
running costs of the play and if so over
which period thank you chair
um who's going to start off
cancel it back from Torrington
yes
[Music]
inclusive organization than the support
of loads of volunteers a bend over
backwards to accommodate anything for
the community and they deliver 650
events in a year across multiple
districts
um
and they also run on the finals of a
shoestring pre-covered you know about
anything at all
um
uh that we've had another organization
that can operate in these circumstances
and I think it'd be a bad job if torrage
can't do some some kind of ongoing
support to show how much it means to the
district as it hits a menu of the
cultural targets of torrage
uh I appreciate that we've got the
financial strainers it is
um
you know a lot of many authorities have
got the same strain
um
but one thing has been made harder for
the player over the years is not knowing
what kind of money is actually coming in
from support wise you know it's been
very hard to mouth and yeah it has every
year it's trying to guess
who may or may not give money
um
I think that's tdt
um we should be supporting them
I would like to say that we should go
for the 25 but uh being able to have a
realist I'm kind of reluctant too but
I'm gonna suppose that we will roll back
a bit to 10 000 a year for three years
which we'll see in up to our 50-year
anniversary
and hopefully I'm going after that as
well but we'll work on that later
thank you
thank you Christy
um
[Music]
that's pretty good news but can I ask
one thing
um when the general manager of the brown
spoke she did say that background was
predicated
on page six I read it is understood that
funding for the council is not an
essential purposes for the organization
to be able to draw down
which is which is true
my understanding of the position is that
in the bid it was set out that an amount
would be raised from local authorities
that is undefined which local Authority
should make up that fifty thousand
pounds so if George didn't make a
contribution there'd be 50 000 pounds to
find from other local Authority
organizations
oh I don't think I'll put my microphone
on sorry
um can I come back then because I've
already mentioned I sit on the budget
working group where you know we are
literally now looking to save a thousand
pounds here a thousand pounds there
um
and it's become very difficult but the
player I think does represent a really
valuable thing in the whole of storage
and it was open I was listening to the
uh general manager spoke to speak
um it did come back to me once when the
toilet was set up in 1974 they asked
where was going to be the headquarters
where was Central to torridge and it was
Torrington
and Autumn can suggest something
slightly odd I'm going to suggest that
um we do support the plow but we do it
by taking 250 pounds from each of the 36
councilors
um local grants for three years that
would give them nine thousand pound for
three years and I say that because that
torrage
is a big area but times who is in the
center and all the councilors all the
people who live in our Wards we will
benefit from the plow and I think we
should all chip in I don't know I've got
a second of for that but
foreign
[Music]
ten thousand pounds
look what it brings in look at them
tickets
a colossal number of people from from
this this District benefit from it
well
it's a type of match funding we've got
to show I mean now they've got a look to
North Devon
a bit from them they just it has to be
I'll support it
thank you
uh counselor private folks thank you
chair I'm just going to ask a question
about the 50 000 if they don't make the
50 000 what happens to the rest of their
funding
is that jeopardize
this might be a question better directed
to the representatives from the player
but my understanding is that the funding
uh over the three years has agreed but
it would properly jeopardize future
funding applications if they weren't
local commitment towards it that that
might not be 100 accurate and so it it
might be prudent to ask the play
Representatives
[Music]
object
um
how that figures
there will be dialogue between ourselves
and the Arts Council about whether we
achieve perhaps they are
all lines
but that is
currently
yeah
so is that to hit 50 000 each year or is
it to hit 50 000 in total
because obviously if we're giving 10
each year that's
an annual
right
advanced
I do know there's a gap from North deaf
um
thank you
I think at times
in parts of the district there is a lack
of awareness of the actual work that's
actually undertaken and achieved by the
plow
their outreach program is most
impressive and has been for a long time
but is particularly impressive and I'm
not getting into a swinging match but
the the plow generally in the past until
this grant came has financed itself or
everyone who uses Services of the plow
pays to attend or go on a course or
whatever it is
they're not a museum
and therefore they don't get the free
footfall of school children's visits Etc
when we look here at the burden I remind
members that we give a generous we have
a generous service level agreement with
the burden
um which only three years ago fell below
the hundred thousand pound a year mark
is now at less but we are still handing
over a significant amount of money where
um
and yet arguably the Outreach from the
plow
um is is greater
um
it's not just Torrington it happens to
be located in Torrington but actually if
you looked at the membership of the plow
and the usage of the plow it's drilling
as I've been said from across the whole
area so it's not a Torrington only asset
some people try to actually pigeonhole
it like that it just happens to be
located in Torrington
um personally I would have said fifteen
thousand but the proposal is ten
thousand I would support that
um
if anybody's anybody who's involved in
these things knows that these type of
Grants they they require to see some
investment or involvement from a local
Authority and otherwise
if the local Authority isn't minded to
give anything at all then obviously
there isn't a cause so
um
[Music]
personally I would have said 15 if the
proposal is 10 fine
um I I'm afraid I do not agree with
councilor Christie this this although
it's discretionary and although you will
desperately take for money the actual
return on this is considerably greater
than some of the other things we spend
our money on so I support Council breaks
motion councilor James thank you chair
I would reluctantly support Council
bright as chairman of the um the budget
working group we've got enough nightmare
Central Library to our Twitter but also
I'm involved in as you know the Wingham
Road in also everywhere we are
struggling and probably go and go to the
war but there seems to be an attitude
sometimes that stuffing the countryside
we will go on and do ourselves but we
can't do everything I think the player
is good for the area and and whilst I
don't need any more whereas on the
working group I think what comes about
ten thousand over three years is is
acceptable so I'd support it
thank you chair control bike well I'll
let it just test the water and see who'd
be in support of 15 it was mentioned
and right the only comment I would make
I I was a little bit
um concerned right on page 13 under the
Run Bay
the outdoor performances mainly in the
summer
more than 50 of them fall outside
Torrance District
yet we seem to be the only District
Council subscribing
which concerns me a little bit
uh councilor Hudson
um
the the amount is obviously far less
than the plowder hoping for
however I think we shouldn't tie
ourselves down to a fixed figure for
three years
I would propose that
we fund the 10 000 this year and review
our position as a local Authority
at this time next year
um our fortunes may change I'm ever
hopeful I'm an optimist and if we have
the way with all to increase that next
year
for years too and year three I think
that will be a Way Forward I think to
tie ourselves down to a fixed figure it
does help our our budget planning
admittedly but I think we would be
better off doing that and then it will
be seen that we are doing what we can
know in very hard times
uh but prepare to review it in the light
of better fortunes lying ahead in the
future thank you your proposal that is
an amendment
yes Mr chairman thank you is there a
second after that first of all yes
I must can I just say I fully agree with
councilor Hobbs and my thoughts
precisely it's difficult to look ahead
and know that there's some requests that
has been reduced and reduced but nobody
knows what the situation would be like
next year we've heard about how dire our
finances are we looking to save money
anywhere we can some support the plan
was obviously essential which is a
worthwhile
um worthwhile place
um but I still have to go to council
hopefully we should look at that again
next year I don't agree with cancer
Christie's I have here
a new Council
should be allowed to make their own
decisions as far as that goes and who
knows whether the council or Grant will
still be here next year as well that may
well be rescinded due to the the
situation the council finds itself in so
I'll share this support that Council
Hudson has said
could I suggest that there is still a
commitment for three years but actually
we're saying
a minimum of ten thousand pounds to be
reviewed on an annual basis thereafter I
say that so that the plow have the The
Surety of being able to say to their
other backers
storage are definitely supporting us for
the next three years which is the period
of time which they're they're in
receipts of their grand funding and the
way that councilor Hudson was talking
she was not I think suggesting that it
would be cut but hopefully we might find
space for some more would it be more
helpful perhaps if we were to say that
that was a minimum for three years so
there was a commitment over three years
but we were leaving the door open
possibly to to increase it if we could
afford to do so thank you chairman
thank you
thank you for letting me speak I'm
actually on the committee as you all
know and I just think we need to
recognize the added value so we're
talking about figures here but actually
what that means to Torrid as a whole it
gives us a lot more than that 10 000 and
we need to recognize
um just a small amount of funding from
this Council will give a huge amount of
added value meeting a broad range of our
strategic aims health and well-being the
Vitality of town centers raising
aspirations and inspiring our young
people which is exactly what we need
here into it as well as meeting our
cultural strategy as dreamer mentioned
before
I would urge us to show a commitment to
the plow to allow them to thrive and
continue to attract funding from other
external sources and as Council laws
alluded to said it is a type of match
funding and that's what this is it's
showing that commitment to the plow and
I feel support councilor Newton talking
about the minimum of 10 000 and
reviewing it because I think that would
work really well with the Arts Council
as well knowing that that commitment's
there but we could increase it if we
were able to as a council and obviously
it will be a new Council in place as
well so it'll give them a bit more
Independence in how they want to support
the plan thank you
attention officer
thank you
um I've been pondering uh Council of
Newton's proposal uh while councilor
Butler Hunkin was speaking about making
some sign to the plan however
are not only optimistic and prudent
and I think to commit this Council going
forward for three years when we do not
know what lies ahead
I commit fully to ten thousand pounds
for this year and I commit to a full
review
next year
I am going forward because I think it
would be
um lacking in
Prudence to actually commit to an
ongoing payment we have done this before
with other groups and bodies and entered
into long-term Arrangements which in
different times may have been the
decision might be might have been
different so I so councilor Newton on
this occasion I can't agree with your
proposal
just going to say thank you chair
um we seem to be overcomed occasionally
the question is are we going to commit
ourselves to the plow in the same manner
that the other money has been committed
and I feel that the 3 10 000 over three
years is a way of showing that and I'm
fully aware of the fact the finance
manager sat behind me in it the next
working group is going to ask me are we
going to do it but that's where we are
and you know I'm involved with stuff
that is really struggling financially
but I think it's it's the commitment
that we know where we are as a council
and the organization knows where they
are and I think we've regained several
suggestions so slowly getting muddled a
coastal brights were straightforward can
we commit ten thousand a year for three
years and I'm all for that can we start
debating it every year and what we can
afford to do no that's just over
complicating it
thank you Chad
Anderson Newton seems happy with that so
I'm back basically for the two
situations
is technically an amendment I think
yes I bow to your wisdom Chad
so I'll speak
yeah can I just confirm chair that
councilor Bright's proposal was ten
thousand pound a year for three years
consecutively
um
we seem to be nitpicking an awful lot of
the parent the cloud is a brilliant
successful it really is we talked we
signed up to the north Devon cultural
strategy
at the heart of that for me is
councilor Newton mentioned look at the
service level agreement we have with the
boat that we spent tens of time
we're talking about 25
000 pounds and that's it dropping the
ocean actually
but I'm happy to support what cancer
granted when I read the report yesterday
ten thousands came to mind but it should
be a Simpson a chair for three years not
not reviewing it it does give some
services and of course they do mention
the Arts Council to do mention in here
about the support from local authorities
and I think it's it will very really
close can't
why
I'm Chancellor Hobson's
Amendment to the vote those in favor of
please share
one two three
four
those against
one two three four five six seven so the
amendment is lost
then we come to catch the great proposal
those in favor ten thousand for three
years please show
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
those mechanics
abstaining two
thank you
foreign
okay so I'll do a short presentation
happy to take questions at the end they
have anything pressing during the
presentation so what will the
presentation cover our recap River
Council was this time last year I've got
a brief refresher and the sausage of the
council's finances
uh website for that council tax of
something called council tax support
funding which is moved with the
financial year 23 24. uh I'll talk about
the 2000 that's actually it's a tower
program actually said the
2023-24 provisional settlement so
apologies are
um
support and funding again that's my
mistake next slide please Kirsten I'll
talk about business right revaluation
some of my key assumptions and setting
the budgets the risk of sensitivity
where was it all mean for the 23-24
graduates summarize what this means for
the medium-term financial strategy I'll
give you some recommendations and next
steps at the end of the presentation
next slide please Kirsty
so there you go this time last year my
hope as you can see on that chart we
were forecasting deficits accumulative
left us from 1.4 million with the
council basically coming back into
balance hopefully about 26th 20th
century the Blue Line there the blue is
the deficit the clouds of excel rising
and then declining by 26-27 and the next
slide please
I have a transitioning government from
the reserve which we use to balance the
budgets until such times we can find the
relevant savings I'll bring the budgets
back into balance and that was a
projected balance on the transition on
Government funding Reserve you see we
start off 21 22 with a 1.7 million in
the reserve and we declined to just over
a quarter of a million by the end of the
medium-term financial strategy period at
26 27 so that's my phone
so I'll turn my phone off I do apologize
next slide please
so just a recap on the sources of the
story council is funding you've got a
pie chart there and there's four
component the by far the biggest source
of our funding is our freezing charges
which you approve some increases to
earlier in the meeting
then we've got business rates of 29 from
council tax at 25 and actually our
settlement from central government only
represents seven percent of our gross
income when we ignore and housing
benefits subsidy okay next slide please
okay and this is just a reminder for
members whilst we encourage in our
capacity of willing Authority collect
the council tax due with inter it's the
vast vast majority of the council has
collected on behalf of our preceptors we
don't keep it most of it goes obviously
Devon County Council we receive over 72
so the chart that you can see on the
left-hand side we've got something in
red that's a total council tax bill the
next bar chart is Devon County Council
followed by the police and just behind
is ourselves at toast District Council
then the fire and then the various
parish and town councils next slide
please
so I share the council tax has been
going down and down and down for a long
long time and that's because of our
restrictive referendum limits compared
with some of the other preceptors
there's no referendum limits for our
town and Parish councils and there's
been an adult social care preset for
over the last four years for Denver
County Council and there's been some
significant
um
increases in the police precept that
they've been able to take so I'm
forecasted in for 23 24 Irish share a
mechanical touch bill is 8.18 and it was
nearly nine percent back in 1617. next
slide please
okay so this table shows the impact of a
2.99 council tax increase in 23 24 2.99
is the referendum limit for a shire
District Council like torridge
and you've got most bands down the
left-hand side and you've got um the
band's a b and c highlighted in I'd say
green
um and that's because the majority of
people with Windows Live in bands a to c
about 68
so the in part uh if we put the
referendum up to the referendum and a
band C would be four pounds 75 pounds of
the year which would be nine Pence a
week so that's our impact on and
taxpayers across then the council's area
next round please
so risk immigrating for 23-24
has been good with introduced something
called council tax support funding and
in recognition the cost of living crisis
central government has provided funded
to mitigate the impacts of rising in
council tax for those in receipt of
local council tax support and the
support is capped at 25 pound per
household tires will receive funding of
103 000 pounds any funding left over
after capping council tax increase in
flows on local Council transport can be
used to support economically vulnerable
households
um for most recipients a local counter
transport this means effectively won't
have any increase in their council tax
liability for 23 24 and if you just go
on to the next slide
uh probably hopefully demonstrate that
so I've taken abandoned c as I've
previously indicated the majority of
people living bands a to c over 68
. so we've got on the left-hand side
there the
2022-23 band Sea charges and you see
them at the Devon County charge the
police the fire ourselves and the
average for the parishion Town Council
that comes to about
1907 pounds and then the projected
increases without various referendum
limits I've had to take an average for
the parish and town councils whether
that be true I'm not entirely sure at
this point so the third common envelope
says
2023-24 council tax I'm saying that the
bill for advancy is going to be just
over 2 000 pounds which will be an
increase of just under 95 pounds
however if somebody's on full council
tax support
they will only have a 25 liability so
they'd only have a liability of 476
pounds
if you do those increases it'd mean that
their bill will go up to 500 pounds
which will be an increase of 23 pounds
72 and as I said earlier there's a
capping so we can reward up to 25 pounds
to these people on local council tax
support so therefore they'd effectively
get 23.72 in support and it'd have no
increase in their liability and in
Reddit says 80 percent of recipients of
local council tax support receive the
full amount either get 75 relief
um so that's live please
so we had a settlement from central
government
um the settlement was only for one year
so we don't know what Grand settlement
we're getting um in structural years the
rural Services delivery back which is
our biggest steam program that wasn't
what lifted by inflation for the third
consecutive year and that's essentially
occurred 10 with inflation being as it
is at fifty thousand there's an
introduction of a funding guarantee
Grant to ensure that all councils have
at least three percent increase in their
core spending power the core spending
power of a council is it's the income it
gets from council tax business rates and
central government grant
and new homes bonus was confirmed only
for 23 24 141 000 for ourselves no
Legacy payments and obviously that's
becoming some terminal Decline and we
got about two million pounds for that in
1617. the revenue support grants was
uplifted by inflation and now
incorporates two previously separate
grants which is the council tax and its
Grant and the local council tax support
Administration Grant next line please so
everything there's a chart
so on the left hand side there's a bar
chart that says Toad and it's above it
says 4.5 the average increase in the
comprehensive spending power for Shire
districts was five percent ours was four
and a half and as I just said
comprehensive spending policy in can we
get from council tax retain business
rates and central government grants and
then grow a very sort of sectors of the
local Authority family so to speak so if
you see
um Metropolitan districts have had about
a 10.2 percent increase in their core
spending power the green line that goes
across the top is inflation so clearly
our settlement from government is
significantly lower inflation it's half
of what inflation is so there's been a
cut a real term put in our comprehensive
spending power next slide please
okay so from the 1st of April
23 there's been a re-evaluation of
business rates which and the gross
rateable value of business rates within
Terror it has risen to 45.4 million from
40.8 million now there's about 4 000
properties liable for count business
rates within Torrid
uh business rates from income from
Renewables which is 100 retained by the
council increased to 717 000 pounds from
605 000 pounds that was a win far for
the council that's life please
there's been a variety of support
measures introduced by the government to
offset the impact of the business route
re-evaluation
so the most important one is there's
been no increase in the multiplier
that's actually the rate in the pound
that these child done business right
that's for a full fuel it's been frozen
no the good news for terrorism is we're
compensated for that's lost in Combined
section 31 Grant
and there's a 75 relief for all premises
in the Leisure retail and Hospitality
sector that relief was 50 in 2223 where
it's capped at 110k per business
and this transition only for businesses
Capital mayor increases at 5 10 or 30
depending on their available rate so
even though you rate triple value may
have gone up you don't pay the full
rates bill in the first instance and for
any business no longer receiving small
business rate relief there as a result
of the development of the result of the
revaluation their increase is capped at
600 pound they can only be allowable for
600 pounds more business rates if
they've gone out a small business rate
let's lie please
so where's that leaders and the budgets
so you've got a chart there and you see
in the blue line is our expenditure and
if you see in the red line is our income
so actually for 23 24 we're quite close
to balance and then there's quite a big
gap develops there and 24 25 and that's
because some non-recurrent things are
coming out such as the evaluation of our
approved provision for business rates
amongst others and the Surplus on
business rates and then as you can see
there's a more sort of even pattern
between our expenditure and our income
but at no point do we um getting to
balance over the next the duration of
the medium term Financial strategy so by
the 2728 we've got a gap of
240 202 I think it is
um and if you recall when I said where
were this time last year that I was
expecting to be in Balance by 26 27
obviously that hasn't proved to be the
case next slide please
and so what's happening on the
transition government funding Reserve
clearly we're dipping into our building
Society account to balance the books
over the period of the mcfs and we
declined to um a balance of 144 000 by
the close of the medium term Financial
strategy next slide please
so what's the key assumptions I've put
in the medium term Financial strategy
I've assumed that the business rates
will put business rates I do apologize
the council tax will go by the
referendum numbers at 4.9 for each year
of the median term Financial strategy
Central governments found in settlement
for 23 24 when you enrollment the value
of the 2324 settlement that has been
largely assumed over the life of the
medium-term financial strategy I've
assumed with Revenue Support Program
I've got about some inflation but Lively
I've assume if they're getting 23 24
will be replicated in each year going
forward
business right I've assumed some growth
in the underlying
businesses of 1.5 and where we've had
planning applications received for
renewable energy schemes an estimate of
the additional business rates that could
come true has been included when the
median term Financial strategy so I've
taken
an estimate of additional renewable
energy business rate income next slide
please
I've also had to make some assumption
about the income we'll get from our
short-term treasury deposits of interest
rates I've assumed for three percent
over the life of the median term
Financial strategies that currently
three and a half percent
um I've also brought in some reduced
treasury management income reflecting
that at some point as we start to
develop the environment Center and the
maritime Innovation Center will start to
actually spend some of the money that we
hold in shorts and treasury deposits to
actually fund our capital projects
income from fees and charges that key
assumption is planning income I've
assumed 790 000 per year over the life
of the medium-term financial strategy I
know in your report I show
um the availability that we've had in
planning income over the last few years
um I've been seeing that employers
pension contributions will be 19.5 over
the life of the medium term Financial
strategy and contribution to the
underlying pension deficit will increase
by twenty thousand pounds per annum over
the median term medium term Financial
strategy period next slide please
I've assumed a power route for 23.24
with five percent and it's doing the
payroll to two percent for the remainder
of the median term Financial strategy
and I've also assumed that the current
weather expandage on temporary
accommodation which is 1.3 million
um we mean our obligations to residents
at risk of homeless has been assumed for
each year of the medium-term financial
strategy next slide please
so I've talked about the assumptions
there's obviously risks on the budgets
if I get the assumptions are wrong and
they're erroneous I could model
almost numerous things I've just modeled
some and I've included them in the
report so next line please
so if counselors decide not to increase
the council tax in 23-24 the additional
cost of the council will be 132 000 next
year and 23 24 rising to 156 000 in 27
28 and that bar chart there shows the
deficit in blue
is as my projections and the one in red
show the consequences if we didn't
increase the council tax can I have the
next slide please
and that's more of the more pertinent
one here is what happened the transition
and government funding Reserve so the
blue line is sharing the decline in the
transition Government funding for
example you've called from a previous
slide uh it's forecasting the balance of
144 000 pounds by 27.28 if you only
Fargo increase in the council tax for
one year that deficit exceeds half a
million pounds by the time we get to
27.28 and actually expires somewhere
between 24 25 25 26 at which point there
will be a challenge for the council
actually set in a balanced budget
because we wouldn't have anything in the
transition government funded Reserve to
bridge the gap uh match live please
um and one of them as a German part-time
the transition and government funding
Reserve if I get the power award wrong
so if we have underestimated the payment
by one percent for 23 24 and 24.25
you get the blue line again it was
having a bounce of 144 000 pounds left
in it and then you see that the balance
would be the payrolls were out Dakota
we're probably going down closer to like
700 000 pounds 750 000 pounds so it
doesn't take
too much on some of the assumptions to
be wrong for quite big movements to
happen on the transitioning Government
funding Reserve next slide please
um so I've assumed interest rates would
be three percent for the duration of the
mtfs
I mean just to show what a year we've
had
currently the interest rates are six
three point five percent there were 0.5
when we set the budgets back in February
2022 our valued it increased by Seven
Fold over a 12-month period based on
projected cash balance a one percent
movement interest rates will impact the
council's income from Treasury and
short-term treasury costs by 125k per
annum so that could be all odd out if
they go by one percent we'd gain another
125 000 per annum it went down by one
percent we'd lose 125 000 per annum
um central government funding is
detailed in the report the 2023-24 grant
fund has been used as a basis for
estimating Grant income for the median
term Financial strategy the government
has now set a fair funding review will
be undertaken at the start of the next
Parliament that's the first interview is
just equity and funding looking at needs
of cloud source and dispute whatever
potential is available for local
government based on these and
reassessing it
given that shower districts like toad
with benefit motor and retaining
business and Rose income some of the
street distribution of funding across
their local sectors to be expected but
that's not built into the median term
Financial strategy I'm not second guess
the output of a fair funding view or any
staging or transitional Arrangements
that will be able to ease the burden for
those authorities that lose out
financially next line please
so hopefully we'll come towards the end
of the presentation
so the mtff projects deficits for each
year and the transition and government
funding Reserve is projected to be
loudly exhausted by the end of 27-28.
did we have any significant essential
interest rate per award then the
transition government fundament can
easily tip into an overdrawn position
clearly further remedial action is
required in addition to that audio and
taken by the member budget worker to
bring the council's finances back into
good order next line please
so what can we do well calisthenics
Leisure providing actually told that to
explain HTML grant funding options to
increase the Energy Efficiency across
the council's luxury facilities and thus
reduce costs
you've just approved a separate report
for section 106 monitoring charges which
will improve the financial performance
of the council
and where the council continues to
explore opportunity to secure additional
hostile accommodation in order to meet
the challenges faced by the current
housing crisis in very simple terms the
more hostels we can deliver the greater
savings to the Council next slide please
so there's a little table there
I'll just try to explain it
at the top to the Top Line it says
funding Gap t g f r utilization that's
the funding Gap that I've already
demonstrated to you and as you can see
we're all quite close to Hunter housing
closed for 23 24 to 55 000. we've still
got a gap of over two hundred thousand
and twenty seven twenty so that's the
cumulative deficit of 1.2 million
um so that leads us to balance on the
transition equipment finished at the end
of the period and everything goes
exactly as I said on the immediate term
financially of 144 000. then underneath
you've got some income that we could get
in from the sexual men or six monitoring
fees Helen alluding to the report
earlier in the meter additional income
Energy Efficiency within the Leisure
sector hopefully we can get somebody to
find some efficiency and save some costs
and we could hopefully we could maybe
provide some further hostile
accommodation our hostels like silly
house or like Huddleston it's about 90
000 pound benefit to the council
UEFA you can see we'll have a revised
funding Gap so if you look to the right
hand side you see a figure of 255 so
what I'm saying is we could bring down
the cumulative
deficit over the food too basically a
quarter of a million just over quarter a
million pounds and the fundamental we're
left on the transition in from
transition equipment funding Reserve at
the end would be 1.1 million obviously a
few things have to add this um baskets
after philosophical expression of that
limited expression a few things have to
fall into place for that to occur
and I haven't at the time of writing
English report had anything additional
funding for the plow and I figures
obviously you've agreed ten thousand
pounds a year for three years they would
have to add it back into those figures
um next slide
so these are recommendations that
members of this committee recommend to
full Council retired Bandy council tax
for 23 24 increases about 2.9 2.99 from
178 pounds 66 to 180 for a pound the net
revenue budget is
11.155 million the contribution to
reserves outlined in paragraph 11.4 the
report are approved and in Mark of the
rest of the council's finances
identified Report with a member budget
working which would continue its work to
bring the council's budgets back into
balance I think that's their last slide
I am happy to take any questions
[Music]
councilor Christie yeah can't you say
it's an excellent report
um I managed to follow it this time it
was really good
um and it's uh I think it's really good
news that renewable energy is
subsidizing our council tax and I hope
we get a lot more and we need to remove
the obstacles in our local plan I hope
that's going to happen fairly soon
um the one great thing that intrigues me
is on page 42 of our agenda we have the
uh the preset by different groups you've
got Devon County Council and so the one
that intrigues me is the police because
if you if you recall just a few years
ago rare preset went up by 10 and now
it's gone up it's double rolls again and
you'll see it's by far the largest
increases if our strip every other
preceptor and yet we're all there we
talked to people in the rural areas
you'll never see a place
um could we ask the police commissioner
to come along to torridge one day
to ask answer some questions on this
because I find it intriguing that they
keep upping their precept by far more
than anyone else
and yet we don't seem to get much
further now and I'd like to have her
here just don't ask about that I know
it's slightly tangential to this but I
always find that in truth
I assume we can always ask
um
thank you um again thank you for that uh
very detailed Sarah and and
whatever a presentation
[Music]
a couple of points
in your growth towards share of council
tax collected
um could I perhaps caution New South
slightly as to how you populate your X
and Y axes on that graph the difference
in that graph is 0.8 of 1
um and yet the visual effect you create
because of the scales you use is
actually something really quite dramatic
and that the graph tumbles from one side
to the other the actual percentage
difference is not actually that great
it's in other terms one would say that
the take is roughly stable it is down
but it's a bit it percentage-wise it's
much the same so all I'd say is that
just you know as we all have to caution
ourselves a time to be careful with our
graphs
we continue
councils to live beyond our means and
We are continuing to dive into a very
limited reserve and even with the the
the potential proposals uh which would
lessen the amount that we raid our
Reserve
it can't be good business sense
Now by far creating the report by far
the greatest amount of our income is
from a discretion rather often
discretionary era of our foods and
charges where we're generating ourselves
we must take a business approach to it
I
I would like to see in the
recommendation the final point with the
budget working member working group
actually they remit strengthened
the directions at the moment because it
was put into their terms and conditions
at the outset that they could not look
at anything that might create a
redundancy
that ladies and gentlemen is a matter
for Council to decide on a particular
measure when it is brought forward that
is a consequence which we should be able
to see in the full round of things the
budget working people have had to look
for many of those at the moment because
actually it was put in in the original
terms and conditions
um voice texting to Remember by the
chief executive uh in that meeting and
if you look at me go back to the YouTube
of it
that's where it started
so as a result the budget working group
are basically still only been able to be
an outpatients Department
and actually our budget we needed to go
to General Surgery
um and I I think they they I believe
they've done very good work within the
the
um the constraints that they've been
placed upon them and I believe actually
that we should widen the uh ability of
the budget working group as to where
they can range and look in the future
because I think as they've already said
they've already taken a lot of
low-hanging things anyway
um and the scope of where they can go
next within the very tight constraints
it must be limited thank you
um we have certain Savings of about
three quarters of a million as I
understand it
um I think what we've tried to do is to
try and look at is the low having food
but what we've tried to do is to look at
what we can do so we don't impact too
much on our uh people within the
population and within the members of the
people of torridge
um we've done that by raising some fees
and we're still lower them a lot of
outcome neighbors and fellow District
councils
um
I'm not sure I don't want too much power
to cut
by Barbara I think at the moment we've
gone from where the reserves were going
to disappear to where we will have some
reserves left government policies that
we should be using all our reserves to
prop up our budgets and some councils
are screwing that they've got no
reserves now anyway so how are they
going to use up their reserves to keep
the budget going so I think the Privacy
that we've shown over the years you know
yeah it's been David and before David
but we've kept this Council very healthy
we're in a really peculiar situation in
terms of the budgets
um and I think at the moment
we're not doing too badly and I'm quite
happy to support the recommendations as
they stand I'd like to see the working
group one taken off by then that's going
to happen
um so I would like to move the
recommendations as they stand thank you
chair
I think you've moved on I'll address it
to an officer afterwards check
I'd like to Second the recommendations
in this report and commend it to council
uh there's a pie chart about
um where our sources of income comes
from and we've got quite a large section
us from fees and then there's a quarter
it's about uh council tax I mean is that
kind of a general picture from other
councils or do they is there much
variance in that
what you were signed is that a shire
district will have a lesser proportion
of its funding from central government
grant than a Metropolitan District
because it doesn't have adult social
care and Children's Services
the amount of income a district
councilor will get from income is highly
valuable so for example we get over
probably 1.3 1.5 billion pounds in car
parking over places which are not in a
tourist location wouldn't receive that
kind of volume of income and a deprived
say Northern Area may not receive the
same level as planning income as well
because it's not that growth and
planning so we can that will vary it
tremendously most shy districts I would
imagine would have similar proportions
of business rate retention because of a
benefit from the business rate retention
so
but there are unique circumstances here
without saying particularly this unique
circumstance here would be our parking
income relative to our size
with relatively large I believe you went
with all the charity of the country
I as ever will not vote for this budget
because I will not vote for increases in
council tax to our residents and I think
David's done a lovely job as ever and
um put the case for increase as ever and
I note the five percent pay award
possibly and I'm sure there are lots of
people within our district who had left
to have a five percent pay award and
aren't likely to get it
um
a lot of people get council tax relief
and a lot of people don't and we need it
and we've just increased our fees and
charges and we have a new homes bonus
which in the past we actually have been
on Shaky Ground with that yes it's not
as much as it used to be but we are
getting something
um and when the interest rates go up we
still have reserves so we are earning
interest as Xavier pointed out so I'm
not going to vote for this and coming
back to councilor Christie's point about
the renewable energies it's brilliant
that they're coming forward however it's
a real shame that of reading the press
that so much money has been paid to win
Farm owners to turn their wind farms off
when we're in an electricity crisis
because the infrastructure was not
fought through before it was put in
place so
I mean I rest my case there I just will
not vote for this I'm afraid
James could I just point out the council
adult that if we don't
um let's try and get this straight in my
head if if we don't put that council tax
the deficit will become greater the
reserves will disappear we will not get
any interest on our reserves and had we
put up council tax I can't remember 10
years ago was it uh if we put it up then
we would not be so far behind on the
curve as we all know so sometimes given
a bit or taken a bit saves you a bigger
cloak at the end of the time so we
actually set ourselves in in this road
of struggling for money when the
government
and be able to tell me what it's called
the government
um Top-Up money that they've given us
instead of raising the council tax when
that stopped and we decided as a council
we would not put up council tax for two
years we simply slip behind the curve
and we've been behind the curve ever
since
one other point that I just wanted to
comment on and that was on the the
potential measures recommended uh
looking forward and we're talking about
energy efficiencies within Leisure and
energy efficiencies within active
storage
there's there's always a double side
slightly to that in that there is no
suggestion or allowance that those
energy efficiencies almost certainly
will require capital expenditure because
we're talking about new lawyers that are
energy efficient or we're talking about
going to
more efficient or green ways that there
will be almost certainly a capital cost
there and the capital cost will be will
come to us yeah I mean he's also hopeful
and expectation that we'd seek some
external funding
for for others we do have some reserves
outside for investment our Leisure
filters but the intention would be
you obviously try to maximize what
external funding could be available to
mitigate some capital investment
absolutely I'm just saying it it needs
to be balanced and I think we were only
quoting really one side of the equation
for that stage
you know
I distinctly remember the period you're
talking about councilor James and it's
the only time I've ever felt happy that
we actually had the courage of our
convictions to Buck the trend and the
um constant expectation that we would
put more and more pressure on our
residents to pay for what we provide
and a lot of people gained from that in
Services however you represent a rural
community as do I and I think you would
agree that in the rural areas
we don't get a lot for our money
and now I've had several parishes come
to me concerned about the village Halls
which are Community hubs and have 20
percent less rate relief than they did
have so there is a constant pressure on
our rural communities as well as our
urban communities I admit that I will
stand up for them our parishes have the
ability to raise their
um rates more than we do and actually
the ones that I've attended haven't
raised their precepts at all to their
Merit I think
um so you know there comes a point where
you say enough's enough will manage
[Music]
in that aspect of our budget to decide
I think distinguished bands
I've shown there as potentials I mean
until you made the decision to approve
the section 106 monitoring I am included
that in the budget because you hadn't
made that decision uh I've put as a
potential it's not in the efficient like
hostile accommodation we need to secure
a site and that's not easily done and
find the site and it is the same with
the Leisure yes it's not guaranteed and
I'm not budgeting for it I'm just saying
these are potential ways we can bring
the budgets back into a better semiring
to balance but there's other factors at
pair we may find there is no external
funding that can support Energy
Efficiency but it doesn't mean that it
wouldn't be an Avenue that we'd look
down to try to reduce our liability with
supporting measure
right how can you go to local government
for 54 years
and every year of those 54 years
it's been the worst year ever first
setting the budget
so there's nothing there is that
yeah the only proposing I have is that
we accept the recommendations printed
we have to take a reported vote on this
oh councilor down
but I'll propose we don't accept this
budget do I have a second
right
this situation
I was just saying Council that doesn't
need to propose that because
uh but it's still not going to be
unanimous and so we have to do a
recorded notes and
thank you chair councilor bright
or cancer Christy
councilor diet
against
councilor Hicks for cancer Hudson
councilor Hurley for councilor James
councilor Knowles councilor lock for
councilor Newton
that's 10-4 and one against chair
okay thank you
can move them to item 10 Capital program
Pages
56 to 64.
[Applause]
I'm taking this one
good morning counselors
um so there's an update on the capital
program
um for next year and for the duration of
the medium-term financial strategy next
slide please
um so the capital program covers the
next five years and it consists of
approved pids which these are funded
from our reserves
um contributions from our Revenue
Capital receipts and various grants
so at the bottom we've got the capital
program brought forward which is for the
current year which is 22-23 we currently
have a capital program which is
basically 26 million with funding of 28
and a half which gives us a small
surplus of two and a half million next
slide please
um now the pressures that the capital
program is under um some of these have
come from the new homes bonus
um 50 of this used to be allocated to
Capital
um but this has been in sharp Decline
and is likely to cease in the relatively
near future
um the next major pressure is inflation
um as everyone as you're all aware we've
got significant increases to inflation
um impacting on all of our capital
projects we also have the environment
Center project this is adjusted largely
due to inflationary pressures by full
Council in December 2022 next slide
please
um so for the new new pits we would
normally at this time of year add new
pids to the capital program
um but due to
both funding pressures and inflation
pressures
um no new pids are sought for uh
inclusion in next year's program
however
um during the year there are some
projects which have come up and these
projects are ones which sort of
alleviate The Wider cost pressures that
the council is facing and they're all in
the homelessness area so these are selly
house and the Sully house modular units
these were both approved by CNR in March
2022 and the hubblestone conversion
which approved in July 2022. next slide
please
so where does this take us for the
current program so we have the
Brookfield program there we've had the
amended environment Center which takes
us to 24.6 million the homelessness
projects
um takes it back up to basically 26
million
and then we also need to extend the
program for an extra year to take it to
the full length of the medium-term
financial strategy
that takes it back to
26.9 million and gives us a 2.2 million
surplus
now at this point we need to mention the
vehicle program because
um although it looks like a sizable
Surplus actually the way we fund the
vehicle program is we look to when we
need the major Refreshers in the in the
fleet
um so we've actually funded this all the
way to
3233 but what that means is over the
five years we're saving up
um for a replacement of a fleet which
hasn't happened yet so if we split the
program we've got there into the vehicle
program and the general program what you
see is that we've actually got about and
you see the 853 which is the almost 900
000 of surplus in the general program
and the rest is for the vehicle is sort
of taken up for future Vehicles next
slide please
so with that in mind our 900 000
um the program is under future pressures
none of these are certain but just to
give you some idea
um we've got Leisure
um which we've got the three centers
um some estimates in the past have been
six hundred thousand per site per year
which over five years would be nine
hundred thousand there is some funding
put away in a reserve for that as well
um electric vehicles we've looked at
electric vehicles
um just for the smaller Vans and had
some estimate of over 300 000 the larger
refuse Vehicles would most likely be in
far in excess of this we also at the
moment we've got no new pids included in
the program from
23-28
the linear defense project where we're
working with the environment agency
still a bit of an unknown and then we've
also got future inflation
so overall it just shows that the
program's under quite a lot of pressure
although we still do have a small
Surplus at the moment
next slide please
um one thing to mention at this point is
that we have the epidural clean Maritime
Innovation Center will be a large
Capital program so we've just received
word that we've been successful in 15.6
million of grant funding
um the council will provide the site
down at middle Dock
and we'll be borrowing
um to meet sort of the extra costs the
costs above the grant which there are
expected to be but overall the project
is designed to be cost neutral which
basically means the extra borrowing that
will be required which will be an impact
on our Revenue budget will actually be
matched by extra income from renting out
the the units that we generate
um as this is capital program it will
need to be approved by full Council once
it's finalized it'll be um
book to them to do so
next slide please
so that comes to the end really so
we just need the recommendations and
that's for members to recommend for
Council that the capital program is
included or updated to include formerly
Sully house Sully house module units and
the hubberstein conversion
thank you happy to take any questions
I Believe In the initial assessment it
was around a million
so
thank you
yes
about climate really
um
bearing in mind that our budget for
climate is 10 000 pounds this year which
is the same as you've just voted for the
cloud
um I'm sort of intrigued to know how
we're going to further our carbon
reductions
of commitments
um because as councilor Newton said that
if you're going to you'll have to borrow
uh to introduce
um carbon emission reductions that is
the catch for this Council given its
financial situation
um just like to talk get clarification
um it's just been referred to The
Maritime Center that we're borrowing for
that on the basis that there will be an
income coming in in terms of borrowing
for solar projects there are our
buildings
uh does it not make sense given our
financial situation to borrow for pretty
immediate income uh cost reduction
energy cost reduction gains from solar
and I wonder whether David can still
clarify that forms I don't think about
the clarifier are the points that you
made their counselings but in terms of
say the Leisure facilities clearly the
biggest consumption of gas and
electricity in the facilities we have is
our Leisure facilities you're heating a
swimming pool so you're using far more
energy than an office
so I think that's why we're looking most
in that area and I think just general
employment is to try and see what
external grant funding is that we do we
don't believe we're going to secure a
source of funding external funding not
fund the entire
replenishment of the Leisure facilities
to make them carbon neutral at low cost
to the council we'll clearly have to
close some of our own resources in a
future alludity to regret reserve of 521
000. so I think in terms of tax you're
not just imagine that would be the best
place to start that's where the biggest
consumption of our facilities is I
wouldn't know
um I know we've got energy
done I'm not too sure if it was solder
on Riverbank I'm not sure what
um capacity issues we'd have to
investigate where we're getting several
on a another office accommodation would
make commercial sense but it certainly
would make
commercial center with some sort of
grant funding to reduce the energy and
that's consumed in our Leisure facility
because that's the biggest area of
consumption and the biggest pressure of
biology facilities as well
candidate from the energy survey for
extra
carbon saving motion
I'm just interested though within the
property budget is there scope within
the zoom of the property Department
how's the budget does this go within
that for interviewing production
measures also supposed maintenance
ability
I think every measure would have to
stand on its own merits I mean in bed I
don't know the answer but if you
invested a hundred thousand pounds in
solar panels you'd expect X return in
terms of reduced energy and then you
could just do the maths to work out if
that was a cost effective a cost
efficient way of doing it you've got to
remember the property team at the moment
about the environment Center they've now
got the maritime Innovation Center
they've got the priority of trying to
delivers additional hostile
accommodation to meet our housing crisis
we kind of stretch those resources so
far
thank you there's traditional elements
to that I guess so uh tonight at 12
council members you'll have your
strategic Asset Management strategy uh
put forward uh before you uh if that's
approved the next stage of that is
looking at the council's association
determining the the best use for them
um the second area I guess is you've we
or the council has set up a climate
change working group and the aspiration
was that working group would bring
forward ideas and proposals to this
committee to Community Resources for
projects to be possibly funded and it
would be this committee then which may
allocate or recommend to full Council
projects to take forward but as such
nothing has come forward to date so
chair we went to see those projects and
then councilors can consider them in the
lives of what's available in the capital
program and the revenue graduate
as we sit here in our lesson it just
occurs to me that we could make our
biggest carbon savings by closing on the
legis and the tastes kill two birds with
one stone
but but
we'll go right back to the agenda if we
may Council Christie yes um
[Music]
are we still doing that so I know
there's an Old Chestnut but it's uh you
know 800
000 pounds uh completely screwed up the
whole thing but um but we still got a
hundred thousand pounds in our budget
for this
and child responded today
um that's what members decided to leave
in the capital program
um in the event that we would need to do
that as part of delivering a local plan
in the future so it was something that
was looked at and members at full
Council decided to take an amount out to
that budget I can't remember off the top
of my head what it was but to leave a
hundred thousand there
because
clearly
we're working on a local plan now new
local plan where there's going to be
full one or abbreviated and we've never
actually achieved Egyptian traveler site
under the last local bank and it was
picked up you know this was quite a big
problem
um I'm just wondering is that going to
go up do we
State and say
we're going to sit and guess what it may
to be
um
actually in the capital program is that
just a few pure uh money value or is it
kind of budgeted using the expected
gains from assets that we might need to
sell off
um that there are some capital receipts
in there although we did dispose of the
larger ones last year such as clevewood
and Bridge buildings
um there are quite a lot of forecasts in
there so obviously some of the money we
haven't it's over the next five years so
some of the grants some of these
projects will run on grants so some of
that isn't there as of yet so we don't
hold uh 27 million pounds in reserves of
capital and we've probably got more
around five or six million and the rest
is sort of future future Revenue
contributions uh Capital receipts from
um General Capital receipts and selling
some specific things such as the three
Depots when we build a governmental
Center
um a plan to go into the vehicle program
and so there's quite a bit of
forecasting in there which is why
um chain which why it needs updating
every year as well
yeah uh yeah is there any any assets
that we haven't bought before that's in
that all of them just haven't been
mentioned what that as part of this like
land that we're selling off at any point
it's not been mentioned before uh not
not that I'm aware of now
so was this for nothing more
recommendations
I think 16.
my apologies
well we're going to recommend to the
full camps of the capital program with
three items to go forward all of which
we've committed ourselves
I'm happy to make the recommendation Mr
chairman hi
as listed in the report
all in favor
thank you
no one else wishing to speak on any
anything would come to the end of the
agenda and I can declare everything